need motivation watch a top 10 with
belief nation hates Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you as well you've got Michael Jordan
level talent at something so get ready
to change your environment develop
valuable skills and change the way that
you think about money with Dan Locke and
my take on this top ten rule success
value 15 to give you the confidence
motivation and belief that you need joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
1 change your environment I always say
that your willpower is never as powerful
as your environment a lot of times maybe
you want to change you want to make a
new decision you want to take a leap of
faith you want to do something new but
your environment is not supportive of
that the people around you your family
and friends they're not supportive of
your new goal your new vision that you
have for yourself or maybe in terms of
your environment where you live in that
is not supportive of where you want to
go so instead of trying to fight with
that I always say change the environment
change your environment it's much more
powerful because your environment is
more powerful than your you will power
your your discipline so what can you do
to structure and create that environment
so that it's easier for you to
accomplish whatever it is that you want
to accomplish rule number 2 develop
valuable skills instead of thinking now
we in we're no longer in a job economy
we're in a skill economy that you need
to think much more like an independent
person with skill set that you offer it
could be two companies or two different
businesses or to the marketplace instead
of thinking or a job we provide for you
you need their flexibility right
developing what I call the high income
skill and I'm number of videos on
YouTube you can search on youtube
download high income skills you'll find
that so don't think arms in the job
economy that job economy their
credentials economy where
a piece of paper a piece of paper is not
going to protect you when there's an
economic downturn a piece of paper is
not going to prevent you from being laid
off a piece of paper it's not gonna pre
friend that your industry turn upside
down and then this massive change that's
happening it's not gonna protect anybody
what no one could take away is just you
set the value that you know you could
provide to people to the marketplace to
companies no one could take that away
from you so focus on skill not just a
job rule number three change the way you
think about money you've asked me all
the time Dan why they talk about money
all the time you see there's nothing
wrong or evil about money money is
neutral imagine if you enjoy talking
about basketball
Raptors NBA Canadian team right if you
enjoy playing basketball or watching
basketball would you be ashamed to talk
about basketball with your friends your
buddies no you wouldn't
then why would you be ashamed talking
about money you see you have a story in
your mind right now about health about
success about life and also about money
you have a story in your mind right now
and guess who created those stories it
could be your parents it could be your
relatives it could be the people that
you know you're loved you're brought in
sisters your cousins it doesn't matter
but you picked up those stories from
somewhere remember when you were a
little kid the horror story the scary
story the spooky story the boogeyman
hiding the closet someone planted those
thoughts in your mind and someone
planted those thoughts about money in
your mind as well that it's hard to get
money that rich people are bad that you
have to do something bad to to make
money and and it's one thing to make
money and it's very difficult to keep
money and if you make the money and now
you lose it then you look really really
stupid but it's simply not true the
people who are struggling with money
they're afraid to talk about money and
believe me they do talk about money the
difference is they argue all the money
the
parents argue over money do you argue
over money with your loved one your
spouse your boyfriend and girlfriend I
remember one of the few times in my life
that I saw my mom cried was because we
ran out of money so remember money
secret number one money moves to those
who are not afraid to talk about it
rule number four hold yourself
accountable most of us live up to other
people's expectations we don't want to
disappoint other people so let's use
that don't just rely on your
self-discipline
let's say you have a goal instead of
just keeping that to yourself and say
I'm gonna work on there I'm gonna work
on that and when I get there then I'm
gonna tell other people about it
No do the opposite do what I do tell the
whole word about it
declare to the whole world this is who I
am this is what I'm gonna do this is who
I want to be these are my goals and you
tell the whole freakin word about it the
world will hold you accountable just
like my youtube channel I declared in
the beginning I'm gonna hit a hundred
thousand subscribers with it that I
declare to the world we're gonna hit a
million subscribers by the end of 2018
we did that now we've declared the word
we're gonna hit ten million subs guess
what we're gonna do that I don't hide to
myself and say oh I'm just keep it to
myself these are this is my goal no I'm
gonna tell the world we're gonna do it
we're gonna do an eye we're gonna do it
together it's the same thing also if you
want to have more confidence check out
my to 54 series it's free the link to
join is in the description below that's
a problem with young people you're not
good at anything oh good no tell me the
truth you're not good at anything after
you practice martial art you develop
this natural self confidence not
cockiness but you develop this natural
self confidence remember this your
business is always a reflection of you
rule number five do what you love this
this village and the government wants to
develop this village so they send some
of the top agents to talk to the chief
of this village and these agents they
showed up to talk to the chief and say
hey chief we are planning to spend
millions and millions of dollars
building infrastructure helping you to
develop this village
and achieve its like okay so what are
you planning to do the agents are saying
you know what chief is what we're gonna
do we are going to have some buses we're
gonna send a lot of buses to your
village the achieve it's like okay so
why do we need buses well we're gonna
have all these buses we're gonna have
you we're gonna educate you we're gonna
bring your people and then we're gonna
bring them to a school
the chief is asking well why do we want
to go to school the agents are saying
well when you go to school you're gonna
study different subjects and topics and
so that you could get a a diploma or a
degree the chief is like okay so what
happens after we get the degree and the
diploma oh then you'll be able to
graduate you're gonna be able to find a
safe secure job and achieve it's like
okay so why do you want it safe secure
job oh come on chief when you have that
safe secure job then you're gonna be
able to make some money you make some
money then you're gonna you can have
kids your people can have kids and then
we can get a house so okay so and then
the chief cycle Canada and then what oh
then you get a house and you put outside
some some money and then you work many
many many years until you're 65 and
guess what chief and you can't wait
tired and the chief it's like okay then
what happens after what time what do you
mean what happens after we time it after
what time you can do whatever you want
you can go fishing you can spend time
with your family you can go hunting you
can do whatever you want
the chief looks at the agents and saying
I'm doing there right now I'm fishing
and hunting and spending time with my
family right now why didn't it go
through all this process the moral of
the story is this that sometimes we are
chasing with so focusing on the goals
and we sometimes forget why do we want
those things in the first place
it's what I believe is a very important
lesson I want to share with you it's not
just how much money you make is how you
make the money knowing that money is
just a vehicle is a means to an end at
the end of a what is it that you're
after rule number six stop using the
word try I'll try to do something well I
tried see when you use the word try the
minute you use that word you are setting
yourself up
failure you're giving yourself a way out
when something doesn't work out well you
know I try I try my best
I try to call you man right I try do
this with me I want you if you're
sitting down if you're standing up you
doing something you're watching me right
now listen to me I want you to try to
walk a step forward try to walk a step
take a step no no I didn't say walk a
step
I said try to walk a step towards me go
ahead no I didn't say move a step I said
try try to move no I did not say move a
step I said try to move a step you see
the state of trying doesn't exist it is
a made a [ __ ] story that we created
in our own minds the state of try it
doesn't exist either you do or you don't
there is no such thing either you move
what you take a step forward or you
don't take a step forward there is no
try try means nothing it means nothing
happens so eliminate that word from your
vocabulary rule number seven take action
now one of the things I teach all my
students who are learning closing from
me very simple I teach them a role play
a day keeps property away right every
single day you spend at least invest at
least one hour role play and honing your
skills it's as they're simple it's an
integration it's not a well today I
don't feel like a little role play or
maybe I'll do it tomorrow and then you
procrastinate and you don't do it for a
week and then guilt kicks in so I know I
should have done there but I didn't do
it now if I do it it's kind of too late
I look stupid in front of the people
these all these BS if in your mind
versus hey you know what we do in our
day and now they will play period that's
it there's no thinking I don't want you
to think about it I don't want you to
hesitate I don't even want you to do it
just integrate it into your life every
single day I'm going to do an hour wall
play period if you want to improve your
clothes
skill you see it takes all the decisions
making out out of your thoughts all
these spears in your in your mind take
that away and just do that rule number
eight expand if you're serving a local
market if you are making money in
general income from just working with
and serving people in your city expand
that so instead of focusing a local
market how can you take what you do and
offer to a more global market so when
this economic downturn in your country
and I know our friends in you know over
the world in your country or in your
city you're not depending on it when you
are serving people in so many different
countries right because usually when
there's a can economic downturn in this
country this is booming right if this
there's a problem with this country
right and this is booming so instead of
focusing on a local market serve a
global market rule number nine don't
quit
have you had moments in your life when
you feel like you just want to give up
then no one it's coming to help you no
one is coming to rescue you
then you've tried everything you
possibly could to solve the problem
that's in front of you and just feel
like quitting I've had many many of
those moments in my life and in my
career as an entrepreneur I faced
various challenges competitions problems
on a day to day basis and then many
times in my life that I felt maybe I
couldn't solve this problem maybe I
couldn't overcome this maybe I should
just quit
I'm not gonna give you some rah-rah
motivational talk and say hey just don't
give up just hang in there just don't
give up what I am gonna do is to share
with you some of the things I've learned
when I've gone through a lot of ups and
downs in my business career to get to
where I am today
that what do you do when you feel like
you want to quit when you feel like
quitting what do you do you see whatever
that's in front of you whatever obstacle
that's in front of you right now and you
feel like you have done everything you
possibly could that yes I have tried
everything to overcome this my question
to you years
have you tried everything have you
talked to enough people have you read
all the books that you could on this
topic that you seek mentorship have you
seek help have you done everything you
possibly could have you taken all the
actions that you possibly could to
overcome this have you my guess is
probably not
because if you have you would have
already gotten the results you see it's
never a matter of lack of resources it's
always a lack of resource fulness that
you're not created enough that we are
not created enough that we don't think
outside the box enough and sometimes
when you get so close so close to your
goal a lot of us we just give up we quit
when we are disclosed to achieving that
goal you see success is on the razor's
edge of failure when you think it
couldn't get any worse when you think it
couldn't be worse than what you're going
through right now when you think it
couldn't be any tougher
that's when breakthrough happens
sometimes in life you break down before
you break through and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is have fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
such a loser
thank me later
[Music]
I do today in room now I have a special
bonus clip from Dan on how to circulate
money that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one what do
you need to stop saying the word try -
number two
where do you need to hold yourself more
accountable and number three what simple
change can you make to your environment
to give you more confidence and if you
like this video and will take action
after watching it give me a hash tag
believe down the comments as well now in
Chinese the term making money Duan chin
he also has a separate meaning meaning
to circulate money Swan chin it's not
just to hold on to and keeping and not
not spending it is to circulate it you
see whenever there's a contraction the
economy what does the government tell
you you go out there and you want spend
money right go spend money consume hired
a new employee go stop their new
business make their investment go on
that trip right buy that car they want
you to spend because it keeps money
circulating so money goes to those who
know how to circulate it in terms of in
business right go open their new office
expand that's how you keep billions and
billions and billions of dollars going
and that's how you create momentum in
the economy same thing in sales a
salesperson a closer could circulate
money because they are making money move
without them they would not have make
that self that sell will not be there
the goods and services that transaction
will not take place so money goes to
those who know how to circulate it hi
this is Dan Locke if you're a fan of
Evans work if you want to know exactly
how the model my success I want to
invite you to join me for a special
online training all you have to do is
click on a link below you can join me
for absolutely no charge so click a link
below and I will see you in class
if you want more den lock checking my
top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
they're moist right ooh chase them on I
want to make the money I want to make
the money you can see these people
they're so desperate they don't make
money you don't make money if your life
stinks it's your fault